so let's start on the macro level like
was there ever a lull and then we'll get
a little bit more finite because the
people listening that uh
you know are especially people i'm
there's gonna be a lot of people
listening that love running and they're
gonna get it and they've done a half or
they've done a full maybe um so this
stuff is going to be so interesting but
from a macro level do you ever take time
off
in the year when you were in when you
were competing
uh i'm going to tell you this when you
run a marathon the next day is a force
with him out so you know
i hate to break it to you but you know
for us as you train you train your train
so intensely you know
and when you run a marathon your cross
will be sore and you're going to be in
pain and then it's like it's the first
time out you know and for me i take
about a week off maybe two weeks off
depends how i recover and then and then
then gradually just start walking but
make sure you stretch and things like
that but yeah it's not a season say like
football basketball season over and get
them out it's like spring marathon fall
marathon and a lot of races in between
so the only time you take time off is uh
after the marathon because
oh yeah no doubt okay good that's good
to know i'm literally thinking to myself
make sure you take a week off after
if meb takes a week off after i should
take a week off after because my mind
would probably tell me like four or five
days later i should probably do like a
like a flush run or something like i
should probably just kind of run like
three or four miles and just real easy
but i'm taking a week off thanks to you
um so then what was the actual amount of
time that was condensed down to
specifically for the marathon and i know
it's a little tough because like a lot
of people will just do a random marathon
and you know they have they need a lot
more training to prepare for that one so
you have kind of an all year sort of
sort of con conditioning but when you're
getting that that last little bit
specifically for a marathon how long
does that last for you
the marathon training yeah like right at
the end because you're always training
for a marathon
right right i mean people often say is
you need 16 weeks to train for a
marathon or 14 weeks of training for
marathon it all depends on the condition
of the person and somebody can pull it
out in eight weeks some people can pull
it out of six weeks it depends what
their previous
fitness was if somebody's driving from
scratch and then hey let's walk around
and whatnot and you could use the 12 to
16 weeks but i think for me
since i always been fit since college
collegiate years and professional and
the least amount i have done is eight
weeks and you know i was injured recover
from the injury and then you know you
don't lose much you in terms of fitness
but mentally you lose a lot because
you're not
day in day out weekly you're doing not
doing the exercise like you have
uncertainty can i make it can i make it
or i might be able to make it but if you
let the fitness come to you great things
happen positive thinking whereas if he
says oh i only got eight weeks and panic
attack i gotta run my long run next week
no you don't need to do that let the
long run be the celebration of 26.2
miles now how do you get whether you're
doing five miles six miles 12 mile 13
mile accumulation of running get into
that race day without been
setbacks or without being injured it's
gonna be okay but if he says you know
what i gotta get
five weeks out i got to do my 20 mile
run and you're only doing six seven
miles you you're mentally defeating
yourself already because you have this
perception but if he says hey i just got
to be smart my previous condition is
whether i done marathons or half
marathon will carry me through this race
i just got to be healthy and be mind
focused and look at that date that
ultimate date of the marathon and you'll
be fine
yeah
what were some of the collection of
modalities that you would use to
stay sharp um i know you talk about
strength training and stretching and all
kinds of things like that like last
night i was thinking i was laughing as
i'm like you know researching and here
listening to you talk about things and
you were talking about doing stretching
after a run for a while and i'm like
laughing to my friend who ran her and i
ran 16 miles and i was like
we're not stretching aaron like like we
we should prob meb stretches afterwards
we don't we're not even stretching we're
just putting ourselves in these sarah
body boots um so um so what it what are
the things that you do that you would
really attribute to being like the
foundation of your of your of your
ability to keep going
you know there was a great coach from
ucla john wooden he says it's not what
you're doing practice in two hours but
how you take care of yourself so the yes
the 60 miles training is checklisted but
hydration
is important normatec or compacts
electronics if you're feeling something
you'd rather just take care of it prehab
instead of rehab because you don't want
to wait until you get injured so you
have to think about the small thing that
says hey i'm in sync with this you know
at 16 miles i felt great now how can i
recover and whether it's tomorrow then
two days i can get a little bit runny so
you have to do i use personally
generation you can soon as i finish my
my hard workout whether it's long run
intervals or tempo i have a packet of
you can uh with a 10 ounce of water that
that immediately is helping you recover
and then obviously the stretching is
important not many people do this but
it's five minutes of your stretching
that allows you not to get injured but
also helps you recover for tomorrow for
next day for next week but if you just
say hey we got that 60 mile run let's
just get on the car and go you already
got intense a little bit your hamstrings
are tired your calves are tired achilles
is tight then you're pruned for injury
so the stretching is not 10 15 20
minutes about five minutes of stretching
the the core muscles that would help you
remember
like which ones are those i mean for
yeah the clocks like
the quads the hamstring the calf the
achilles and the adapter and adductor
and those are the essentials you know
you know some people stretch their hands
is fine but the one that's going to
carry through 26.2 miles is out of the
leg so and the glutes the blues are very
important you know you want to be able
to just because you've been using the
same muscle for 16 miles the same pace
you want to change it up a little bit
stretching is you know when you're
watching tv or you're hanging out you
know comfortable with your friends or
family members it's okay to get on the
on the carpet and do a little bit of
stretching because you get ready for
36.2 miles at the boston marathon
there's a there's an excuse for it so
it's